is the UK about to brexit from the Iran
nuclear deal there is great confusion
after comments made in interviews by
Prime Minister Boris Johnson in which he
said it was a bad deal that needs
renegotiating and that President Trump
was the man to do so as president Trump
rightly said it was a bad deal it wasn't
a great deal Iran was was and is
behaving disruptively
in the region and I think there's one
guy who can do a better deal
Trump was quick to seize and what
appeared to be a change in UK policy I
respect for us a lot and I am not at all
surprised that he was the first one to
come out and say that later though this
statement as clarification the Prime
Minister supports the jcpoa
that's the Iran nuclear deal the
Iranians aren't currently in compliance
and we need to bring them back into
compliance
it all comes at a time of growing
tension the UK France and Germany have
now joined the u.s. in declaring that
Iran was responsible for the drone
attacks on Saudi Arabia's oil
installations meanwhile iran's Foreign
Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif says a
meeting between President Trump and
president rouhani will certainly not
take place this week but he says Iran
will propose a new peace mechanism it's
calling the home OU's initiative which
will consist of all the countries in the
Gulf under a UN umbrella we believe it
should be owned by the countries in the
region but the UN umbrella addresses a
number of concerns first in the UN
umbrella addresses the disparities in
size power anxieties about these
disparities which are always there even
within the GCC as you know developments
regarding Iran are moving extremely fast
and president Trump is likely to devote
a significant part of his speech to the
General Assembly on Tuesday to the
ongoing crisis James BAE's al Jazeera at
the United Nations